Wade I remember why we stopped playing this game..
Because you were to stupid to match my level of skill B )
Yeah
That's what it was
I can't even argue right now after what I just did
Huehuehue
OH! Hello everybody my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Seven Days To Die ^^
With Wade
Hi- HEY GUYS
HEYYYeheh
So uh...
We've had some trouble.... this is our first attempt?
Our first attempt, oh is it? *laughing* I distinctly remember some failures-failure-fade.
There's no proof of that
I'm doing a slow fade into the past!
*laughing* Let it- let it happen
These zombies, there we go got one of em
WHOA
*INCOHERENT WADE SHRIEK*
IT JUST GOT FAST OH SHIT
oh hello hunting knife, I'll be taking you ;)
AH FUCKING COCK ASS, Jesus get ou-no!
Holy shit...I'M INFECTED? FUCK THAT!
What does that mean?
I dont know!
I got a torch on the second flo-oh boy
Oh she found the stairs! errerrrr 0.0
Oh I see
Wade-shriek V2
*DARKIPLIER LAUGH*
DIEEEEEEEE
NO NO NOT MEEE AUGGGHH
Over here over here, aw no you died..
Ugh the naked butt is eating me
How far away are you
I...yeah
Yeah?
Yeah.
THREE KILOMETERS!?
COME ON MAN
ITS NOT MY FAULT!!!
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOUR FAULT
PRESENT DAY
yep..that sucked, didnt it..guys?
Man I had forgotten about those..
It was so long ago...um but yeah, so welcome back to 7 days to die
Uhh
We're here to do a thing!
What man what did we cover this game
it's been two years that's right it's
been two years uh, since we last played this
game which is astonishing really
Yeah
it is amazing how long it has been
That's all you have to say?
Wade
I know you said it before, but you
could say it-
Well I mean a lot's changed and and you know, time's
passed we've played other games but it's
really cool to come back and revisit
some of the some of the classics
yeah I mean there's this game has been
constantly updated because one of the
things in the last last time we played
this was this game was updated like
every two weeks or every week it was
really often
It's somehow still in alpha though despite the fact that
it's been out for a long time
yeah how is that even possible still in
alpha but I mean hey whatever it is it
is what it is
Wait where are you oh I'm not near you
I'm not near you at all
oh no I thought I was near you hang on
I'm a comin'
Where are you?
I'm just a little to the South
I thought I saw you in a building but it
turns out it was not you it was
something else
probably a zombie 'cuz I'm stupid
(strained) I'm on the way!
Don't panic!
Now I remember why we stopped playing this game, 'cuz you're terrible-
There you are! HI! Hello!
Where are you?
I'm over, I'm over there
There you are
Hi!
Hey how's it going
Why do you look like Einstein?
What do you mean
Why do you look like you what do you
mean like me you you have literally
What do you mean like me? You have literally
Einstein hair and an Einstein handlebar
mustache you are literally Einstein
I'll disguise myself a little bit more
really all right
oh yeah now you're a wise old
wizard trying to hide yourself from
me I see
yeah well I got a craft up all that
stuff
I made us our very own usable door!
*Buttery* Wow. on the other one - Oooh I'm very
impressed
Our house comes with a bed a fireplace
one chair and a box
That sounds good I like that
ok oh I am a girl
OH the cactus i'm
going to cut this down
All right I'm trying to, how do I put on
pants
(laughing) I never learned the skill
In order to put on pants in the real
world you gotta press the tab button and
click on character
I got it I got it I got it I got it I
got it I got it I got it
Then you drag them over to the I get it well I
got it and it's fine i'm going to gather
more wood before it gets too late and we
get die
Ok, ok there's one zombie out here
that's just being a bit of a son of a
bitch
yeah yeah yeah I've dealt with a few of
those in my time
yeah I wanted to craft the wooden Club
apparently for my next trick
apparently i really don't know how long
it's gonna take to go through all the
failure that we've had so I I don't know
how long this episode is or is going to
be
I don't know either yeah probably just
best to cram it down into just a minute
or two right
probably the episode's going to be one minute?
No, no no I mean the failure-
(laughing) make it under a minute
I mean you guys watching don't need to
know about any of this this is
is literally behind the scenes stuff
that isn't very important for you guys
watching but (Wade)  there's one minute of
it
There's one minute of it, I already showed
'em I don't need to show it to them again
Wasn't that good, before
Shut up Wade they've already seen it you
don't need to confuse him now
oh yeah I could OH CACTUS
Ohh this is lovely it's a little cabin!
That's so nice (Zombie noise)  that doesn't sound nice
sounds like there's something outside
I stepped on a cactus
That's not what I'm talking about
Are you finding any bird's nests?
Bird's nests,  I found a few around the area
I'm looking for one, I need some feathers
for a bow and arrow
yeah I got you
oh, I found- I found your friend
Hi friend! Whoa that friend is very angry.
Yeah I've got a club here I'm tryin'a
Just stay down for a minute there we go
Yeah the club works better on these dudes
My club broke
Oh he's got hazmat boots that's good is there a radiation-
Woah look at the transformation
Yeah that is bizarre. Heblehh!
yeah there's another- another one
of that in our house is not a another
that uh huh
So oh it's there's no upstairs it's just a
really tall area
yeah this is all we've got yeah
So anyway um, the reason we're playing this
again is because I wanted to play a
survival game with Wade and we haven't
played in a while but also I'm at comic
con right now so I i wanted to get
another series to do while we were away
so this is what we're doing so that's
all my justification for it
I didn't know you were there how's that
going? It's go I'm there right now it's
so much fun look at me I'm dancing! It's so good you're recording with
me at comic con
That's how this works that's how time
works when you're doing things ahead
No one needs to know any different... yeah but I
don't know it's also good to just be
doing a series again because I haven't
had a chance to do it before
oh that's right when we were ballsing out
we're talking about pokemon go
We were talking about that
Yeah yeah team instinct you joined the
right the team I did!  Oh you're team instinct too?
Yeah I don't think anybody
else is team instinct but you and I are
Team instinct, everybody was so mad at me, people right now when they
find out that I'm team instinct
are like uhhh instantly dislike the video
this is bullshit I can't believe it
But you didn't have any real connection like
people joined based on their favorite
legendary bird for the most part for me
my favorites actually Articuno which
would be team mystic but all my friends
were joining instinct and I was like
well I'll go against the grain here and
then I got all the hate for it
Yeah I know people do not like it when
you're not on their team! No they don't!
It's really it's really disconcerting
for the state of society if it's like
(sarcastically) You're a different color than I am?
Fuck you man!! Oh my god I didn't think of it
like that but now that you mention it
that's pretty messed up
It reminds me of when you know reddit
had this thing where there's like team
purple and team orange or there was
different words for it but it was like
that kind of team thing going on and
then it was randomly assigned who is
whose team
so no one ever picked but they instantly
hated the other team without even being
told to hate them, like it became very like
animalistic with the amount of like
disdain they had for the other team just
like automatically from what you were
assigned to it was nuts. And there's so
minimal interaction with other people
I don't understand the hate
anyway the only way you ever come
across any of them is like gym battles
right
Yeah I mean pretty much which I haven't
even gotten a part of why i just turned
level 10 because I got in the game very
late
Yeah I'm 12 i'm not that for much
further ahead. Yeah I did get lucky
because I found
uh an electric eevee what's it called that-
Jolteon. Jolteon yeah I found a Jolteon
and when I found it was level 562
so it was already like at a really high
level and I was able to upgrade it a
little bit so hopefully I'll be able to
fight at some lower gyms with that and
then maybe make some progress
See I feel weird about the thought of
going to battle at gyms because the only
gyms near me are like elementary
schools and I don't want to be that
random twenty-seven year old walking or
driving to an elementary school in the
middle of summer and parking in the
parking lot. You know, you know what's
funny is you're probably not
the only one that would be there it would probably be surrounded by adults!
It's it's just so bizarre for like this
game is just so bizarre because I keep
seeing videos of people like in the
middle of Central Park and just like
sprinting towards like a charizard that
spawned by like a tree somewhere
randomly and there's like people
stampeding each other trying to get this
this like one Charizard. I've seen videos of
them in here in Cincinnati it's not been
like that but I've not been downtown or
anything but I've seen the videos of
like hordes of people going running
across like a crowded street to get to
some vaporeon or some random pokemon that spawned. Oh yeah I went down to Santa Monica
pier recently because I was trying to
get some water pokemon and I've seen so
many videos of like other youtuber
friends of mine that were down there at
a certain time
oh shit is night. Yeah I'd- I would crouch
and hide your torch maybe so we don't
attract any unwanted attention
Okay well it's super dark we need some
light to be able to see your beautiful
face so that we can talk to each other, right? Oh your eyes are like yellow
Thanks man I'm Team Instinct through and through
I don't know. Now that I get closer it just looks
like you're really high. Thanks man, I'm Team Instinct,
through and through. *inhales*  Yeah, uh,  but
yeah so I went down to Santa Monica but
the like the second I got there the
servers went down like it's just been
unbelievable
Did you know that game is made in unity? No is it?
It's made in unity which explains a lot
of the problems that they've been having.
I mean you and I have played some unity
games in my life and I I don't imagine
that it's any better
I've seen some really beautiful things done
unity but there are definitely a lot of
problems with it
Oh yes. What's the new engine what's
the new thing people should be jumping
on?
Oh man I mean unreal is like another
engine the people's- do a lot of, I don't
know what engine this game is built in, I
think it's actually a custom engine that
they built but um yeah
unreal is like the most popular one
considering it's used by all of the all
of the major development companies
because it's so easy to split between
like ps4 and xbox one and pc development
to do it simultaneously without having
to do much heavy lifting (spooky music) that didn't
sound good what is that
I don't know I don't hear it. Do you see
like the undetected icon?
Yeah the eye is really squinting. Ok
that's good that means we're undetected still.
Okay good
yeah so if it seems boring it's because
we're just waiting out the night we have
spent so much time just trying to get to
each other that we just want to survive
the night so that we can go out and get supplies and start building the rest of what we need to build
Yeah we're not equipped to handle the
running zombies of the night
Oh yeah it is like it's just instant
death because they'll chase you down
you'll run out of stamina and you'll
just die so hopefully that won't happen
to us. If we can manage to find a way to
craft beds we can spawn at the beds and
always manage to spawn back here.
Yeah we could do that. I mean I can make a bed roll right now.
Oh can you? Yeah you can make a bedroll
it's it's just plant fibers so I'm gonna
make that it's going to take twenty seconds yeah yeah
yeah
But anyway back to the more important
subject to pokémon go
Yeah yeah of course. I went down to- when you
came over to LA you went to the
Americana which is a very nice place
it's where i used to live and in
there for some reason because Google
Maps the way it integrates things
there's like seven different landmarks
in the Americana
so there are seven different pokéstops
in the americana which is awesome
because you just see everyone hanging
around the fountain just walk in little
circles trying to find pokémon and
taking advantage because everyone is
placing lures at all the pokéstops
and it's really cool so
I just literally would go there in super
incognito by the way because I don't
wanna  be subjected to the
entire horde of people there but uh and
then I just make little little
inconspicuous circles around the place
and collect all the pokémon that I can.
There's a park near where we used to go
to school that has I think seven
pokémon stops and a gym in it so we've been we've been going over there
and going for like long walks and stuff
Oh that's nice I need to go back to
Cincinnati just to be able to take it
(sputters) that's like my excuse
for going to see my friends again is
only to go collect pokémon like this the
only reason that I want to go. I've got  friends
messaging to me about doing like trips
they're like "hey we should go in a trip
sometime" and it's like do you really
want to go to the beach and they're like
"no we want to go pokémon go"
Yeah I mean there's nothing wrong with
it I guess it's a good thing
this is like such a huge effect that
it's like sweeping every single aspect
of humanity like it's affecting
humanity on a social scale which is so
weird
I mean there are negative like the
people that are doing it at work or
running out into traffic and stupid
things like that they're doing it while
driving but the positive aspect
to bringing so many people together getting
them outside and walking is fantastic. Yeah I can't tell you how many people
like would just stop and be like "hey
there's there's like an onyx over in
that alley over there you should go get
it" and it was like "oh hey did you see
that charizard over there" like all "get
the magikarp over there" is like Oh
everyone's so nice and helpful and this
is lovely and I like it.
Unfortunately nothing cool spawns here
it's just weedles and pidgeys but they do
tell me where those are.
Oh yeah that's a that's pretty cool I
guess I don't know it - I've gotten
the only things I've got that jolteon
and I've gotten an onyx
I've gotten two onyx's actually that
are going to be impossible to level
up because no onyxs spawn so how are
you going to get enough to evolve it so
yeah whatever. Yeah that's true, well you've got a hatch the eggs I
guess get lucky
That's true that would be true but
anyway, it is officially day so we
survived the night!
Yay! And by walking out the front
door my skill in athletics has increased.
Congratulations man i'm really proud of you
So, thank you everybody so much for watching
I hope you enjoyed this episode of
failure and talking about pokémon go!
(laughing) Welcome to seven days of pokémon go!
Seven day to pokémon go! But either way
thank you everybody so much we're gonna
play this for a few more episodes and
have some fun with it and get crafting
and hopefully not die
ok yeah so thanks again everybody and
check out Wade's channel in the
description below for other cool stuff
that we've done together and other cool
stuff that he's done so thanks again
and as always we'll see you in the next
video
Bye-Bye!
Music